[Musik]
noch ist das hier ein ganz gewöhnlicher
kreisel in monheim am rhein aber bald
soll auf dieser verkehrsinsel regelmäßig
ein geysir ausbrechen und wasser zwölf
meter hoch in die nordrhein-westfälische
luft schleudern nein das ist kein
verspäteter aprilscherz das ist der
volle ernst der monheimer stadtspitze
beim normalen volk ist allerdings noch
eine menge überzeugungsarbeit nötig also
ich glaube das ist mal wieder so ein
naja leicht spinnerte idee von dem
bürgermeister ich finde es passt einfach
nicht hierher
ich weiß nicht wer auf die idee gekommen
ist ich sehe da keinen mehrwert drin
auch nicht an dieser stelle wo halt eben
viel straßenverkehr lang läuft und ich
weiß nicht was das soll
in monheim will man kunst im
öffentlichen raum fördern
deshalb soll ein düsseldorfer künstler
auf diesem verkehrskreisel einen geysir
bauen
alle ein bis drei wochen wird die
künstliche quelle dann ausbrechen kosten
stolze 415.000 euro
damit das aber nicht jedes mal kracht
und scheppert muss zusätzlich noch eine
ampelanlage er bei jeder aktion werden
die straßen dann gespart
auf die idee muss man erstmal kommen
aber der bürgermeister steht felsenfest
zu dem projekt wir sind nicht
größenwahnsinnig mona wir sind auch
selbstbewusst mannheim ist keine
verschlafene kleinstadt wir haben
gemeinsame stadtgrenzen sowohl mit
düsseldorfer als auch mit köln in beiden
städten findet viel kultur statt im
monat meines erachtens noch zu wenig und
das wollen wir ändern
durch den geysir
ein solches spektakel auf einer
verkehrsinsel ist das nicht ziemlich
übertrieben
kunst soll ja nicht nur immer mehr oder
nicht in erster linie gefällig sein
sondern man darf ja auch immer über
kunst stolpern oder sich auch die frage
stellen muss das überhaupt oder soll das
so sein
da kennt der bürgermeister seine bürger
sehr gut denn genau das fragen sich
viele monheimer wenn dafür extra ein
bild verkehr eingerichtet wird damit man
den geysir sprudeln sehen kann dann
macht sich der kreisverkehr ja sinnlos
ja ich finde das ein bisschen verrückt
weil man sagt ja auch die einwohner die
dort drüben da hinten noch wohnen werden
in zukunft die haben sich schon gedanken
gemacht ob sie dann nicht nass werden
wenn sie aus der tür raus kommen ja ich
denke der mann bürgermeister der ist
sehr innovativ aber dass er jetzt so
innovatives hätte ich jetzt nicht
gedacht
im rathaus hofft man dass die
extravaganten monheimer wasserspiele zu
einem echten touristenmagneten werden
wenn auf dem kreisel also bald kleine
island entsteht bricht in monheim am
rhein aber hoffentlich der verkehr nicht
völlig zusammen